republicans are pretty good at tactics
present tactics in the moment you just
saw that from greg abbott down in texas
greg abbott is is on the front lines
dealing with this illegal immigration
problem floods of of foreigners coming
across the border biden encouraging it
and now greg abbott's got to deal with
it so he's packing up a bunch of charter
buses and sending them to washington dc
to help local officials
whose communities are being overwhelmed
by hordes of illegal immigrants who are
being dropped off by the body
administration
texas
is providing charter buses
to send these illegal immigrants who
have been dropped off by the
administration
to washington d.c
we are sending them to the united states
capital where the body administration
will be able to more immediately address
the needs of the people that they are
allowing to come across our border
i love this and i hope they're nice
charter buses i love the idea of listen
texas we're going to spare no expense
we're going to put people on these nice
air-conditioned buses and you go right
down to joe biden's doorstep and then
deal with them there the only thing they
get wrong is that i don't think the
buses should go to washington d.c
washington dc is a pretty run-down city
at this point crime is going through the
roof
there's already a lot of
crime and
crime both in terms of violent crime and
also
illegal immigration and all the like
there's already a lot of that in
washington dc and a lot of
the people who are in washington dc
aren't there full-time you think about
the democrat members of congress they go
home on the weekends the democrat
senators go home on the weekends joe
biden's going to delaware all the time
so it's not going to
really make as much of a difference
there i want these buses to go to
martha's vineyard i want these buses to
go to southampton i want these buses to
go to all of the places that the libs
actually spend time in and not even the
cities you know san francisco or
something that is their permanent
residence i wanted to go to their
vacation homes
i want i want the libs to have to deal
with this i want i want them to go to
the upper west side of manhattan i want
them to go to really really nice places
that generally don't have these kinds of
problems
and i want the libs to see it in real
life fun you want to flood the country
with illegal aliens i'll still fight you
tooth and nail on it because it's giving
you a major electoral advantage and it's
just plain wrong
but if it's going to happen don't make
the republicans in texas deal with the
problem
which involves drugs and crime and all
the things that biden said or that that
donald trump said were coming over the
border with illegal aliens
make the libs
deal with it did you like that clip i'm
glad go subscribe ring the bell get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcasts or spotify stitcher or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]